talking about the long run-up to the
next US elections and the things that
the voters are most worried about a
number of other hot-button issues have
fired at public opinion and one of the
most controversial is should
african-americans in the u.s. be paid
reparation for the suffering of their
ancestors who were slaves Democratic
presidential contender Cory Booker
announced a new bill on the issue
however a recent poll suggests only 21%
of voters would support the move if
adopted it would entail an official
acknowledgement of the legacy of
American slavery and compensation
payments to those still affected by
discrimination as a result we have to
recognize that everybody did not start
out on an equal footing in this country
and in particular black people have not
and so we have got to recognize that and
do something about that and give folks a
lift up I believe it's time to start the
national full-blown conversation about
reparations so that we can as a nation
do what's right and begin to heal there
are massive disparities that must be
addressed so we're going to do
everything we can to put resources into
distressed communities and improve lives
for those people who have been hurt from
the legacy of slavery conservative
commentator Anthony Brian Logan an
attorney and author Reese Everson forged
their respective corners on it you could
have identified the former slave master
and the former slave right at that
moment but we're now 150 years past that
particular point in time who's going to
pay people that did not have slaves
nobody alive today and 2019 was a slave
back then so would it be getting paid
for who was getting paid right again pay
it's no more than a campaign promise
from Democratic hopefuls trying to get
some kind of attention now here hey ABL
listen that's the most ridiculous thing
I've ever heard
they provide economic restitution to
those people now if I came into your
house mr. ABL and I sold $1,000 from you
and then I died
or if I stole a million dollars from you
and then I died would you say oh well
Rhys died so the money doesn't matter
anymore no you would go talk to my
children because the children are still
living the benefits of that million
dollars just because somebody's granddad
stole something doesn't mean I'm
responsible for it
if somebody's granddad was a serial
killer and then they'd find out a
hundred years later you don't go after
the kids and say okay you got to go to
jail now or you got to pay back some
money because of what your grandfather
did it makes no sense you know who did
it you should have been able to catch
them while they were alive punish them
while they were alive we want to focus
on is the economic harm that was done to
black people if we really break down
what slavery was people were brought
from across the water to work and that
was free labour so what we have is
generations in years hundreds of years
of systematic distant discrimination and
shutting out of economic access to black
people and that has to be repaid if
we're gonna blame the government of the
USA he is alive right wait a minute even
though nobody's alive right now or 2019
that was a lot bay then and anything
about it is who's gonna pay it you're
talking about that government the
government is funded by the people that
means me that means you will pay for it
so how does it make any sense like I
said it would have been more slave when
reparations would have been due which is
that the end of slavery not right now it
makes no sense this Oh argument it just
it's no logic here America has never
even studied the effects of slavery on
black people they've never sat down and
said we know that as a government we
sanctioned this physics this experience
but we don't even know how far that
experience reaches because no one's ever
study it how much do we owe black people
no one's ever studied it why because the
government has literally buried its head
it's paid out everybody else and and
turned it back on the black people in
America who want to just drive they pay
the money when it was
years that's irrelevant the point is the
era two years three hundred years five
thousand years how long we gonna
continue the narrative at what point do
we say burp at slavery now because the
buck stops here
hopefully my generation will stand up
and say that the buck stops here so we
don't have to go on with this any longer
you